alexander chabalov after an incredible
victory congratulations uh alex
incredible performance with the black
pieces against uh a terrific opponent
all right
thank you so much all after uh last
night i think everything felt good
so
uh
yeah it's unbelievable uh scenario in
our championship right now i mean
larry played the
hell of a tournament you know there was
a and
everything looked like
he's going to
be unstoppable on the way to the title
but uh well
you know uh
we all planted to the end and uh
and
uh well
what about the game itself right so uh
no clearly uh i was preparing for lars
nimto and uh
after
quite a
quite a
long thing he decided not to go for it
and played something
safe
i guess saved but then he allowed this
uh hanging pawn structure which was a
little bit surprising so he played safe
then but i guess
larry also wanted to
clinch today if he could have uh
but surprisingly this game
really reminded me our our first meeting
with larry which was a
u.s championship in 1993.
i was uh
almost the same structure there was like
uh isolated pawn i was on the black side
uh
at some point
where i just
overstepped you know the
limits and
i want
and it did seem like right now he was
building up some pressure right whenever
you move the knife from c66
to e5
how did you assess the position yes and
no i i wasn't too worried i mean so you
were happy with the
impact wide standing pretty active but
uh yeah that's exactly what i wanted to
gives you some chances as well to strike
potentially
uh
so
but of course eventually uh he clearly
overplayed me it's uh
so here was knight on h3 i thought i
could
couldn't possibly be worse and you
weren't actually knight h3 or better
after g5 yeah but then i really didn't
like my position i think rookie flight
was very strong
knight g7 and bishop c2
so there's no time i can
get this rook off i think here there was
a ridiculous uh maneuver proposed by the
engine bishop takes b3 takes and then
rook to c5
to get rid of the rook on
on e5 and
so this is the way to reduce the
pressure okay
and if you go rook to e3 then look to d5
and i shouldn't have too many problems
here okay yeah yeah that looks good
but it's not human to
play just like that
so yeah here larry clearly i grabbed the
initiative and but uh
i think 23 he played like
i mean anything that does not allow me
to trade queens i mean
it would be dangerous
but this one stepped right into actually
i wasn't sure about taking on uh d5 for
white uh
probably at this point from practical
point of view taking on b5 was better
uh at least that's what i thought taking
on b5 and if you do take if you do go uh
with the same queen two currencies
no i think it's the same position only
instead of like a weak pawn on d5
he got two on one and a queen side so
that that's what i but
how does he get on one so a4 yeah but
then i can go a6 right
uh a6 i thought a little dangerous rook
takes b6 6
6
yeah
yeah so i it wasn't that easy to get rid
of those two points on the queensland
and he took on d5 allowed me to trade
coins the worst was over but uh
i think somewhere around here larry
still relied a lot on tactics instead of
uh trying to
like
make a draw i think what him oh so this
was the critical moment okay after 98
g6 would have been quite problematic for
you did you spot this move
oh what
do you want
no no no no no
okay uh
knight g6
uh knight g6 right okay yes
uh
no
frankly i had 40 40 seconds on my clock
when i played 98 uh no i did not look at
it uh oh wow
but this was the 41st move so he had
some time to spend and try to figure
things out oh really yes did he play did
he make an immediate move
to f1
he
he didn't wait until he his time expired
yeah for some reason he played it
extremely fast rook f1 probably missed
some time i i'm pretty sure what he
missed he missed that rook of one knight
f6
uh
knight f6 knight d7
uh
king e7
knight takes f6
takes and d6 i'm sure he was hoping for
that yeah just forgot about that bishop
on a2 is also hanging yesterday takes d6
but i thought that's actually his best
chance to
to make a draw if he wanted to so yeah
picks up the bishop i'll pick up his
bishop he takes b5 takes a3
uh
uh probably f3 i thought just i think
you want to go to
i think you want to go to e4 right so f3
yeah three and e4
uh yeah i thought this this was
promising
like uh i wasn't sure if it's easy draw
but uh
it feels like it was king like that king
gets activated
yeah this should be a draw and uh
so but
for some reason
yeah but he played knight g6 extremely
fast
oh no no no no no no no rook f1 he
played okay and then nighttime
in
which is another mistake i think and
right now it just felt like things are
going from bad to worse for him yes and
the last moment
it seems like it was here
night weight jade yes
to maintain the balance in the position
oh knight h knight h8
oh whoa
and now we get
the end game after bishop takes d5 d5
knight
h6 okay and at the end he takes on h6
you're still better with black right now
but good chances for him to to equalize
oh that's true
well his knight is slightly worse but uh
yeah definitely i i see some chances but
still you're better with with black
right now okay
oh wow so we both were missing a lot
let's get back to the game uh okay
and
when did you feel and
also when did you feel the energy shift
in this game
in this end game right now when did you
feel the energy shift oh i i thought
when he played knight g6 that he already
missed that but apparently it was not
yet but
uh yeah surprisingly white king is
extremely bad you know they made in that
so
that's it
yeah alex congratulations i mean after
that it was a pretty smooth uh
conversion congratulations you're tied
at the top
right now and now hopefully joel will
not lose this
probably not but
it's still in play yeah
crossing our fingers that he's not and
then it's
amazing uh day tomorrow
tomorrow against uh max uh what is your
usual experience with uh
no obviously i didn't play max
too many times well our like active
phases were a little bit uh
you know uh
not not seen her nice yeah when he was
active i i was not that strong yet and
and then later but we played couple of
times and uh
i believe the last
meeting i beat him in a
senior championship at 19 here
so but it was a different color
and max is playing unbelievable i think
he's a he like right now
there's a player with the most energy
i see how he tries to win every single
game i mean it's very impressive so i'm
not gonna take it lightly and well we'll
see how it goes definitely a lot of
energy on your side as well we'll let
you go back get some preparation going
and we'll see you tomorrow thank you not
quite so fast not quite so fast first of
all two quick questions for you alex
first of all congratulations well done
have you ever played bishop at night
versus king
uh in a tournament game
you mean two pieces versus king oh ben
fungal
made me
do it twice
after i did it once i would think
that
you know it's not going to try it again
but no i mean
so i
he's responsible for me you know knowing
this hung game
wonderful so you played it twice but
against the same guy i think he has the
same guy and i think it was within a
year so
okay second quick question for you you
just played around shabbat this is crazy
you just played around
five great legendary play
five great legendary
games ten players
four decisive results
is that a lot
yeah
[Music]
but you guys have been doing it more or
less since round four that you guys have
really been uh killing one another why
the pummelings what's going on
uh
i well
it's very easy explanation there is uh i
think the guys who are not playing that
much uh set in the tone uh max and
dmitry
uh have an unbelievable tournament and
uh
uh even igor melninsky who's uh
um
on bottom of the uh tournament table i
mean plays amazing chess okay so
um people who didn't play for a long
time just wanted to play that's my
explanation
very good well we'll let you go now and
good luck tomorrow
in the championship round yep thanks
yasir thanks dorothara thank you thanks